en ce début d'après midi on s'interroge
donc toujours sur les réelles intentions
des russes au lendemain des négociations
engagées en turquie et qui semblait
laisser entrevoir des signes positifs le
kremlin vient de doucher il ya quelques
instants les quelques signes que les
quelques avancées que se targuer d'avoir
obtenu hier volodymyr zelensky le
kremlin affirme effectivement ne
constater rien de prometteur ni de
percée dans les pourparlers de la veille
on va y revenir dans un instant avec
virginie hertz cela expliquerait que sur
le terrain les bombes continuent de
tomber sur la région de kiev la région
aussi de charny gif contrairement aux
promesses donc formulé hier par la
délégation russe on va retrouver tout de
suite du livre crack du livre bonjour
vous êtes notre correspondant à quai
dans la capitale ukrainienne est ce que
vous avez pu constater ces dernières
heures une désescalade significative
alors je pense que vous voyez l'autobus
derrière moi l'autocar c'est un autocar
d'évacuation mis en place par la
communauté juive de kiev et ce sont
essentiellement des juifs mais pas
qu'eux qui ont décidé de quitter la
ville j'ai parlé à certains d'entre eux
juste avant ce direct qui me disent
qu'ils ne se sentent pas en sécurité et
que ils ont décidé de partir même si il
espère pouvoir revenir dans un avenir
pas trop lointaine vivre en ukraine pour
le moment ils ne se sentent pas en
sécurité même à kiev donc je ne peux pas
dire que l'ambiance se soit vraiment
détendue même si il y à aussi d'autres
gens qui avait quitté kiev pour d'autres
régions d'ukraine et qui sont revenus
pour le moment et tous les jours il y a
de plus en plus de cafés de restaurants
de magasin qui ouvre mais le sentiment
général c'est que même si pour le moment
la ville et peut être à l'abri on ne
sait rien sur ce qui pourrait se passer
à l'avenir et surtout les combats ont
continué autour de ir pin et les autres
villes satellites au nord-ouest de kiev
notamment pendant la nuit après les
russes n'avait pas promis de quitter les
terres qu'ils avaient occupé et c'est
peut-être normal que la contre-offensive
ukrainienne dans ces territoires
continuent mais en tout cas c'était plus
intense hier pendant la nuit que pendant
les nuits précédentes on voit que les
troupes russes quittent le nord de
l'ukraine en partie en tout cas pour la
biélorussie et pour la russie mais de la
vie des militaires lui craignait c'est
probablement plus pour se regrouper que
pour vraiment changer de tactique et
abandonner l'idée d'une offensive sur la
capitale
voilà tout à l'heure le gouvernement le
gouverneur de la région de xian livre
faisait des tas de bombardements
incessants depuis ces pourparlers tenue
à istanbul
la veille peu dans faisons peut-être le
point sur la situation un peu plus au
sud le front sud qu'on continue de
scruter avec beaucoup d'attention
gulliver on a assisté hier à ses frappes
sur nikolaïev ces frappes qui ont donc
touché le siège de l'administration
régionale qui ont fait selon un dernier
bilan au moins 12 morts et 33 blessés un
oui malheureusement je dois vous dire
que le bilan manon s'élève à 13 morts et
33 blessés ça c'est selon le gouverneur
de la région vitaly khimki a aussi noté
qu'il y avait eu des frappes au dans la
périphérie de miku life pendant la nuit
et aussi autour des personnes cette
grande ville non loin de mikko live qui
est la seule grande ville pour le moment
occupée par les russes et j'ai pu
joindre aussi un habitant de la région
ce matin qui m'a dit que l'ambiance est
tendue et que les soldats dans la région
redoutent une offensive possible des
russes et y compris sur les territoires
un peu plus au nord de personnes et de
nicolas yves donc dans la direction sud
on n'a pas du tout l'impression que les
russes abandonnent leurs ambitions
offensives du moins pas pour le moment
merci beaucoup pour ce point depuis le
terrain merci à vous l'univers craque
donc